yeah he'll way to welcome to this video
playing unlock and local from a shaman I
sulagna I thought if someone it doesn't
show up in Iceland right very strange I
thought yes ok so I've got the maracas a
bind with white the same opening and a
head into the game of small just with
colors reversed 97 units it's rare
[Music]
I don't know 24 is that empty aggression
so it's a good it's a good centralizing
move Kincaid won't like it okie dokie is
it going everything I just maybe what
you want so that clean be 630 95 is 95
okay it doesn't it's not that terrible
you know I mean can try to play in five
years
now 23 it's so pretty annoying maybe c5
would have been good actually a 3 was
the kind of move that like okay I knew
you gifted me a move now it's your turn
do we have an idea maybe I could have
actually played c5 instead of of this
really wow both recaptures look good
actually when y yes that low-riding but
he has beaten me two times two wins two
losses so I know it might not be all
that easy i looks bad though try this 96
potentially
just covering those squares and it
looked looks annoying if this is a knife
gets there to eat 67 whatever let's just
to get those squares
maybeee size next size take screen takes
this kind of thing that looks like the
pawn would be very close to promotion
and as a 45 I mean or a4 a5 in fact
that's also interesting
yeah he wants to use this down it's a
hoopty aight i mean this day I that's
very precise thanks for commentating and
what to do I just go back
you
maybe this is an idea he looks a bit
weird but f6f if i get to f6 I'm all of
a sudden being very dangerous against
the skin okay not not here Queen g5f 6 I
know you know what I'm one kind of
either way i'm straying this together as
i go along with this is good now with
the pawn f5 I can bring the bishop over
here and the nidus this is totally
dominated him yeah yeah that's good
that's really strong actually no I'm
threatening f6 winning immediately f6
King takes rook f1 yeah and yeah I mean
I this is the best bishop ever in the
history of chess almost what a bishop
the night cannot move ever that's great
yeah I'm promoting a bigger screen b6
maybe can actually take
now that and then bring the Knight to g5
I was a little sloppy I was sloppy
why does that work Queen takes e7 time
learning
just looks like I'm invading I think
I'll take first as before and check on
it to where this this idea if i go here
Queen a three so maybe this one from
Luke c6 have a king as opener really is
that something have to have to be
cautious see a little bit maybe we
should be success actually an idea it
takes takes as it should be some older
load everything okay hi Scott King edge
and he's got the frigging Luke age eight
more check check check block for fits on
time oh that was kind of shaky it's an
open position there and little it was so
nice and then I am somehow loud stuff I
think again yeah it did f5 is good
that's really good now with the bishop
coming over there like it's completely
dominated you know Chief want well I
don't know maybe I don't need all this
and just should we are now taking is
probably just now on the edge from now i
should just win on the edge for okay why
didn't I do that I was just thinking
okay that should win I mean it does but
it's far less clear and that was that
there was a mistaken idea yeah yeah he's
better geforce hanging glass got seven
seconds him ok 24 is made ok after i had
to play a duplex would hear them I
didn't see that this hangs actually I
mean I would have seen that I saw that
I'm escaping here and this this route
that's all I never saw Queen takes and
so on no yeah I could have just ended it
with on-the-edge film unfortunately I
didn't ok guys thanks for watching